hello my name is reto meier and welcome
to this week in Android development on
Monday October 7 2013 an unfortunate
incident involving a mirror universe
prevented the broadcast of this week in
Android development for the last two
weeks that thankfully might go to cloud
evil twin is just as passionate about
making data transfers more efficient
delivering the final two episodes in the
series covering variable update
frequencies and minimizing payloads
undisturbed by the implications of the
intersection of multiple plans of
existence Trevor Jones also delivered a
dev bite on network service discovery
while in turn Daniel delivered his final
dev by describing how to expand cells
within listviews with the alternate
worlds already colliding Todd Kerpelman
continues to offer advice for mobile
developers with a slightly different
focus with his series of devbytes
covering Google Play game services for
iOS with episodes on using sign-in
buttons and introducing rest meanwhile
in New York and London Nick Roman and
Adam covered the onboarding experience
and collection design in to all new
episodes of Android design in action
back here in sunny Mountain View Todd
and the wolfman were back in action in
game on introducing management tools and
graphs we also launched admin tool and
utilities for Google Play game services
and for those of you that prefer a good
book over watching TV check out this new
guide to managing device awake state in
ecosystem news we saw the proportion of
Android devices running jellybean nearly
hitting 50 percent coming up this week
Todd continues his series helping iOS
developers get up to speed on Play game
services and bruna will need to present
a very special edition of game on in
Portuguese that's all for this week in
Android development be sure to check out
this week's bytes I'm ready Maya and
I'll leave you with these parting
questions you want to live fancy live in
a big mansion party in France